échec au kgb en allemagne fédérale des
spécialistes de l'informatique qui
espionné les ordinateurs occidentaux ont
été interpellés nouvelles inculpations
dans la sphère pechiney celle de max
théret pour délit d'initié pour rester
en liberté encore une fonction report la
campagne des municipales à huit jours du
premier tour le duel chirac joxe à paris
et ses enjeux opération commando à
marseille pour sauver des chiens de la
vivisection à trafic toujours florissant
dans le sud de la france
demain en direct sur antenne 2 les
césars du cinéma aisée ce soir le
palmarès ses favoris là monsieur bonsoir
innues l'époque des blondes plantureuses
celle des chefs de bureaux désabusé
voici maintenant l'âge des ordinateurs
l'espionnage n'est décidément plus ce
qu'il était même si les camps restent
les mêmes car gb d'un côté services
occidentaux de l'autre en allemagne
fédérale un réseau d'espions très
particulier qui travaillait pour les
soviétiques vient d'être démantelé il
s'agit de jeunes spécialistes en
informatique
trois d'entre eux ont été interpellés à
bonn philippe rochot
les pirates de l'informatique faisait
passer leur disque est de berlin-ouest
et berlin-est par le métro le relais
d'espionnage se trouvait à deux pas de
la porte de brandebourg dans un immeuble
et les rendez vous avec les agents de
l'est avaient lieu dans un hôtel de
berlin ouest
là ils étaient payés en deutschemark et
en drogue
c'est en perquisitionnant dans une
dizaine d'appartements de hanovre de
hambourg que le contre-espionnage
allemand a découvert le réseau et
interpellé trois pirates de
l'informatique qui opérait à partir d'un
simple ordinateur domestique
si le ministre de l'intérieur a montré
du doigt les services secrets
soviétiques en parlant d'un coup sévère
porté au kgb
pour lui c'est un succès du
contre-espionnage allemand mais on ne
peut évaluer l'étendue des dégâts avant
les résultats de l' enquête
les allemands estiment cependant que les
secrets militaires n'ont pas été percée
car les pirates n'ont eu accès qu'aux
systèmes périphériques mais en deux ans
ils ont pu faire passer à l'est des
centaines d'informations à trois mois de
la visite de gorbatchev en allemagne
fédérale ce piratage informatique fait
mauvaise impression
mais rien à voir dit on avec la sphère
guillaume à 74 quand on a découvert que
le bras droit du chancelier willy brandt
était un espion de l'est à bonn on
cherche plutôt à minimiser le scandale
en disant ironiquement que c'est une
déviation de la politique de la
transparence la glace nost de gorbatchev
en tout cas si la dextérité de ces
maniaques de l'ordinateur prouve la
fragilité de certains systèmes
informatiques occidentaux
l'habileté de l'homme qui les a débusqué
prouve encore une fois que james bond
doit se mettre au goût du jour
patrick esther nous l'expliquent août 86
dans son laboratoire d'harward
l'astronome américain clifford sol
s'aperçoit que quelqu'un est branché sur
son ordinateur
clifford intrigué constate que le
visiteur s'intéresse de près aux réseaux
de connexion mille net sur lequel
transitent les informations sur la
défense les missiles nucléaires et la
guerre des étoiles
sur les conseils de sa petite-amie
l'astronome montrent un piège
il crée un réseau fictifs et ce design
est le pirate vient régulièrement lire
les renseignements que kiel fort bien
inscrit
le fbi a il prévenu
localise la source de la pelle en rfa
trois mois plus tard une lettre venant
d'allemagne demande même des
renseignements sont auteurs identifiés
entretient des rapports étroits avec les
pays de l'est
le matériel des pirates un micro
ordinateur branché sur le téléphone
il n'en faut pas plus pour avoir accès
aujourd'hui aux fabuleuses mémoire des
ordinateurs du monde entier connectés en
réseau pour pénétrer les pirates doivent
en revanche trouver les mots de passe
sorte de clé électronique ultra
confidentiel une manoeuvre facile si
l'on en croit stephen bernerie un
sympathisant du chaos computer club un
groupe de pirates de hambourg qui avait
déjà percé l'ordinateur de la nasa
c'était difficile de casser des
ordinateurs cela n'arriverait pas si
souvent
en vérité les gens qui installent des
systèmes informatiques réfléchissent
trop peu à la sécurité il n'anticipe pas
les problèmes de sécurité et non pas une
conscience véritablement que lorsqu il
leur arrive un accident
les espions aurait livré aux soviétiques
plusieurs milliers de clés électroniques
concernant le centre scientifique du
cern à genève mais aussi de thomson à
paris de philips en langue les réseaux
par satellite ont par ailleurs permis au
pirate de franchir l'atlantique pour
atterrir dans les ordinateurs du
pentagone à washington les responsables
veulent minimiser la faire plus à
l'ouest à houston la nasa aurait
également été piraté
mais paradoxalement il est très
difficile de dire ce que le visiteur ont
fait à l'intérieur des programmes
escalade de petites phrases dans la
sphère rochdi des petites phrases qui
pourrait signifier un assouplissement
britannique face à l'iran s'exprimant
pour la première fois à ce sujet madame
stade cher en tant que chrétienne at
elle souligné blood cette chaire a
déclaré aujourd'hui qu'elle comprenait
que le livre de salman rushdie pouvait
être profondément offensant pour les
musulmans offensant c'est déjà
l'adjectif qu'avait utilisé hier soir
son ministre des affaires étrangères
téhéran l'avait estimé insuffisant mais
l'auteur salman rushdie sont les 10 1
qui montant de la caution 8 millions
huit cent trente cinq mille
113 francs en échange la liberté sous
contrôle judiciaire pour max théret le
sixième inculpé de la sphère pechiney
chefs d'inculpation délit d'initié le
juge boisé est allé lui signifier à
l'homme d'affaires dans sa propriété des
yvelines
gérard leclerc et de six nouvelles
inculpé
max théret pour délit d'initié de par sa
profession il a eu accès à des
informations privilégiées dont il s'est
servi pour acheter des actions triangle
est en fait racheter à patrice pelât
dans la semaine précédant la reprise de
triangle par péchiney
max théret avait acquis 32000 action
avec un bénéfice de plus de 8 millions
de francs le rapport de la cob le
désignait comme le principal initiés est
relevé dans ses explications de
multiples contradictions et des
affirmations erronées
le président de la compagnie parisienne
de placement paraît pourtant maintenir
sa défense il n'a pas été initiés mais
s'est toujours intéressé aux secteurs de
l'emballage est à trouver dans une
lettre confidentielle
les informations qui lui ont mis la puce
à l'oreille inculpé dans sa résidence
secondaire où il se repose après un
accident cardiaque
max théret a été laissé en liberté sous
contrôle judiciaire avec versement d'une
caution de 8 millions huit cent mille
francs équivalant à ses gains il a
désormais accès à son dossier
du rififi dans le métro à paris
grévistes et non grévistes du service de
nettoiement se sont affrontés à coups de
barres de fer et de couteaux dans deux
stations bilan onze blessés dont un
usager 18 interpellations
eve mettait
22 jours de grève de nettoyage du métro
les parisiens piétine de plus en plus
dans les papiers sales et puis ce matin
des affrontements entre grévistes d'un
côté non grévistes et des policiers de
l'autre dans deux stations du rer nation
et gare de lyon
ce qui s'est passé c'est que un groupe
de grévistes attaquer les travailleurs
qui étaient en train de nettoyer le
métro ces nettoyeurs travailler en
présence des forces de protection du
métro qui sont intervenus pour les
défendre la cfdt ratp qui soutient les
nettoyeurs en grève depuis le début du
conflit à une autre version des faits
les grévistes selon le syndicat aurait
seulement voulu dissuader par oral des
non-grévistes et d'autres balayeur
intérimaire engagés directement par la
ratp de casser la grève
il se serait vu opposer des violences
policières 15% les travailleurs comatex
et son dvd
alors donc tout ce qui bouge maintenant
blancou dans le vent violent parce que
il vient pour empêcher les travailleurs
travailler dans métro ils disent que
vous êtes en grève ou c'est vous qui
foutent et toute la merde hein de toute
la mère de la métro allons donc
alors que nous on a des revendications
sérieuses et claires et nettes
mais là commenté qui fait tout pour
casser la grève le durcissement du
conflit jean pierre soisson ministre du
travail a décidé ce soir de nommer un
médiateur
c'est la chienlit dans le métro un
ministre digne de ce nom ferait
intervenir les forces de police pour la
sq a dit en substance le maire de paris
jacques chirac sur rtl ce matin
des propos ainsi tu es bien sûr dans le
climat de la campagne pour les
municipales
une campagne qui à paris prend la forme
d'un duel sans merci entre le maire
sortant grand favori est le chef de file
de la liste socialiste pierre joxe
l'enjeu véritable le nombre
d'arrondissements que peuvent tenter de
soustraire à la suprématie rpr udf le
parti socialiste rachida en campagne
électorale jacques chirac ne néglige
rien ce jour là dans le 10e
arrondissement son programme prévoyait
une visite de deux heures
de paradis 1h côté impair une heure côté
pair programme respecté à la lettre
pas un commerçant n'aura échappé à cette
tournée générale les poignées de mains
le porte à porte
jacques chirac fait ça presque
naturellement et avec un certain succès
l'ancien premier ministre a bien en main
la mairie de paris depuis 12 ans un bail
signé en 77 et renouvelée en 83 à
l'époque le leader du rpr avait réalisé
un sans-faute 20 arrondissements sur 20
impossible donc de faire mieux surtout
qu'il y a 6 ans la gauche était en
pleine crise le statut nouveau que l'on
a imposé à paris en 1983 qui n'est pas
mon statut
même s'il a quelques côté satisfaisant
conduite a souhaité qu' il en soit de
même c'est à dire qu'on est les 20
arrondissements
ce serait une très grande facilité de
gestion pour ne pas politiser une
gestion du bien nous verrons ce qui se
passera
je souhaite en tous les cas être réélu
maire de paris est restée au service il
que j'ai ce n'est pas paris que jacques
chirac aime c'est la mairie voilà le
slogan de pierre joxe la tête de liste
société prg hawks qui n'a pas le contact
public aussi facile que son adversaire
c'est évident mais avoir un ministre de
l'intérieur en face de soi cela
impressionne peut-être les électeurs
quel qu'il soit la technique électorale
de pierre joxe et simple il ne s'attaque
pas directement la mairie de paris les
socialistes plutôt réalistes ont préféré
concentrer leurs efforts sur quelques
arrondissements plutôt populaire des
arrondissements quasiment sinistrés si
l'on en croit pierre joxe des
arrondissements où le parti socialiste
veut se lancer dans un travail de longue
haleine
il sera bon que des jeunes élus prennent
des responsabilités dans les
arrondissements populaires comme le 19e
le 20e le 11e parce qu'il faudra
tellement de l'année pour redresser la
situation qui vaut mieux qu'ils
commencent jeunes justement vous donnez
combien d'années mais moi je vous plus
très jeune vous comprenez ce parti déjà
de jeu joue le rôle d'ancien un ancien
qui aimerait bien être là encore dans
six ans car pour cette fois ci le
ministre de l'intérieur s'est bien qu au
soir des élections
jacques chirac sera toujours
majoritaires à paris seule inconnue
l'ampleur du résultat les socialistes
arracheront t-il un ou plusieurs
arrondissements de problèmes clés clé en
tout cas préoccupe les parisiens et
alimentent bien sûr l'argumentation des
candidats la circulation plutôt les
bouchons et surtout le logement qui à
paris plus encore que dans les autres
villes françaises coûtent de plus en
plus cher le dossier avec jean pellieux
sylvie messinger habite près de la tour
eiffel ainsi pièce où elle a mis tout le
confort son loyer 3700 francs par mois
le propriétaire lui en demande 9005 elle
propose un compromis assimile le
propriétaire la traîne en justice
mais sylvie refuse de céder à son
propriétaire
nous irons commission si vous n'acceptez
pas nous irons au tribunal
et de toute façon cela a été dit aussi
au bout de votre bail
nous vous mettrons la porte j'ai habité
rue dauphine
j'ai vu la manière dont on a vidé le
quartier des gens qui y habitait
précédemment le côté village de ce
quartier l'ensemble de la france ça
n'est pas paris il faut complètement
sortir paris de ce problème là ou alors
nous dire carrément que ne pourront
vivre apparaît comme ne vivent à
l'intérieur de new york que les gens
riches mais il faut le dire
quatre cent mille personnes ont quitté
paris en 25 ans principale raison la
hausse des loyers les plus touchés les
deux pièces
si dans certains quartiers on peut en
louer à 2000 francs par mois on est plus
près du double dans plusieurs autres et
il faut compter souvent 8000 francs dans
l'ouest et le centre
dans le 5e arrondissement on en trouve
même à dix mille francs par mois
il faut réglementer les loyers demande
de nombreux députés de la majorité
l'assemblée en décidera en avril
le manque de logements à louer est en
tout cas une des causes de leur prix
élevé or les investisseurs privés ont
construit l'an dernier deux fois plus de
logements quand 87 et les 8000 logements
neufs de 88 hlm comprise seront
dépassées cette année à ce fait nouveau
s'en ajoute un autre
on voit réapparaître locations
disponibles dans les agences beaucoup de
logements sont restés longtemps en
agence sans trouver preneur si bien que
les propriétaires ont fini par baisser
leurs prétentions
tout cela fait que pour la première fois
depuis longtemps on va vers une période
où les prix qu'on se stabiliser un
espoir donc prochainement à paris pour
les locataires
carbox délaisse la campagne de paris
pour la corse idée ce soir ajaccio un
déplacement imprévu
il y est dit on à cause de la grève qui
paralyse dans l'île plusieurs secteurs
de la fonction publique à l'appel de la
cgt et de force ouvrière les grévistes
réclament entre autres une prime
d'insularité pour cause de vie chère
n'est certainement pas pour cause de
froid puisque à bastia on a enregistré
aujourd'hui et c'est historique
une température de 21 degrés oui je dis
bien 21 degrés c'est en début d'après
midi à bastia un motif de satisfaction
ailleurs qu'en corse un motif de
satisfaction pour les agriculteurs dans
plusieurs régions du pays il pleut il
pleut n'est pas assez après la
sécheresse anormale des deux premiers
mois de l'année il faudrait pratiquement
de la pluie non-stop pendant plusieurs
semaines pour assurer de bonnes récoltes
et surtout reconstituer les réserves
d'eau pour l'été c'est ce qu'a constaté
isabelle staes dans le sud ouest
il pleut sur la montagne noire un cadeau
du ciel très attendu car de là au dépend
l'approvisionnement en eau de cette
vallée à l'est de toulouse après trois
mois de sécheresse les réserves sont au
plus bas
au coeur de la forêt raymond pireyre
vérifie le niveau des rivières malgré
les pluies les débits restent faibles
nous sommes à la cote de 40 et nous
devrions normalement
pour être tout à fait satisfaisant est à
la botte 70 en aval des cours d'eau le
barrage les kamas il y manque 75 % d'eau
un déficit inquiétant car les chances
sont faibles de reconstituer les
réserves avant juin période d'irrigation
et nous serons obligés d'envisager de
faire un certain nombre de restrictions
c'est à dire de demander aux
agriculteurs de planter des des plantes
qui sommes pas très envie de dos on va
éviter de planter trois de maïs qui est
une plante à vis de nouvelles et l'eau
potable alors pour l'eau potable il n'y
aura pas de problème puisque l'eau
potable est prioritaire et nous
conserverons toutes les ressources que
nous avons pour les besoins d de l'eau
potable pour rattraper le retard il
faudrait un printemps extrêmement
pluvieux c'est le seul espoir de sauver
les cultures d'été avec un risque
les inondations attention pour ceux qui
auront la chance de faire du ski ce week
end
attention encore une fois on risque
d'avalanche hors piste un britannique
est mort encore hier francs suisses sus
aux mangeurs d'ozone
enfin une bonne nouvelle pour
l'environnement et pour l'europe
les douze partenaires se sont mis
d'accord hier soir pour interdire d'ici
10 ans les chlorofluorocarbones
autrement dit les gaz que l'on retrouve
dans les aérosols et dans certains
systèmes de ventilation patrice pollet
une bombe domestique qui libère du cfc
ce gaz qu'ils menacent d'autres planètes
une image qui devraient disparaître
d'ici la fin du siècle
hier soir à bruxelles les douze
ministres de l'environnement ont décidé
une réduction de 85% de la production de
ce gaz
le cfc dont la consommation mondiale
atteint aujourd'hui à 1,2 million de
tonnes avaient fini par trouver la
couche d'ozone au dessus du pôle la
couche d'ozone
une fine pellicule qui enveloppe la
terre et qui filtre les rayons
ultraviolets en provenance du soleil
sans la couche d'ozone
la peau est directement attaqués par les
rayons et celle cancer selon un rapport
confidentiel est divulguée par
greenpeace
en europe la grande bretagne serait le
plus gros producteur de cfc avec 105
millions de tonnes la france arrive
juste derrière 102 millions de tonnes
les scientifiques qui ont donné l alerte
il y a maintenant plusieurs années ont
donc été entendus par les politiques
cette décision est importante elle va
enrayer la catastrophe qui à long terme
menace est au dessus de nos têtes
après demain à londres nouvelle
conférence sur l'ozone et l'énergie à
plus de 110 pays et dans une semaine
sommet européen sur l'environnement à
l'est et puis cette initiative
intéressante a signalées en normandie où
vous pouvez connaître par minitel la
qualité de l'air que vous respirez une
initiative de deux associations de lutte
contre la pollution
ouverture à marseille d'une enquête sur
le commando a mis des chiens qui en a
kidnappé 14 hier ses chiens étaient
destinés à la vivisection est fournie
par le réseau qui avaient été découverts
et en partie démantelé en janvier
dernier en gaz du rejet des chiens pour
la confiture ainsi par les pourvoyeurs
des animaux qui hier devait finir ici à
la timone dans les laboratoires
d'expérimentation
meyer dans l'ombre un commando à temps
et passe à l'attaqué
à l'intérieur de cette aire 5 aménager
la marchandise 15 chiens en provenance
directe du chenil de viols le fort dans
l'hérault un chenil dont le propriétaire
robert capelli est incarcérée depuis le
14 janvier dernier pour vol et trafic de
chiens cela ne seront pas utilisées
comme réactifs biologiques des chiens de
toutes races vendus au poids ou
chercheurs selon des contrats
régulièrement passé avec les chaînes il
agrée chaque élevage ainsi un code de
tatouage mais il faut vérifier car les
trafiquants livre souvent des chiens
perdus ou volés
justement pour les animaux un chien volé
en voici un
grâce au tatouage son propriétaire est
actuellement recherché à montauban par
ailleurs le commando anti vivisection a
pu saisir un document un ordre de
livraison datée du 23 février et donc
périmés mais il fallait apparemment
fournir et vite car ce week end à
marseille doit avoir lieu un colloque
sur la vivisection
de nombreux chercheurs ils sont attendus
interrogé par téléphone le chef du
service d'expérimentation qui attendait
les chiens n'a pas souhaité nous
répondre ce soir les membres du groupe
anti vivisection sont recherchés par la
police
près d'un millier de personnes
aujourd'hui à metz ont assisté aux
obsèques de la petite christelle
l'enfant de 3 ans violé et égorgé sani
dernier l'évêque de metz a appelé au
pardon
éric perrin émotion et recueillement
pour les obsèques de christelle la
fillette de 3 ans enlevé puis violé et
égorgé par un inconnu samedi dernier un
millier de personnes sont venues
assister à la cérémonie après la
libération hier des trois hommes placés
en garde à vue
l'enquêté est au point mort les crs
continuent de fouiller les lieux du
drame
deux ans de prison avec sursis et 20
mille francs d'amendé pour le pilote de
la vedette responsables de la collision
entre deux bateaux qui avait fait trois
morts le 19 87
la vedette avait été prônée vers 10
heures du soir un petit voilier devant
le fort de beaulieu sur mer
le pilote du voilier a lui été condamné
à trois mois de prison avec sursis pour
défaut d'éclairage
ouverture aujourd'hui à paris du salon
de l'étudiant qui confirme son succès
avec 550 exposants le stand le plus
couru l'atelier du premier emploi ou des
recruteurs de grandes entreprises donne
aux jeunes des cours demain tienne serge
me serais on va passer à l'entretien et
puis bah dites moi un petit peu ce que
ce que vous voulez je vous raconte sur
le sujet à l'avant il ya plein de
questions là des questions au détail ont
d'abord quand on a un entretien on se
pose toujours plein de questions comment
être exactement parce qu'à la fois il ya
l'ambiguïté de déplaire
il faut à la fois de se vendre pour les
étudiants qui viennent de terminer ici
c'est le labo antistress la vidéo ça
sert maintenant à se voir en situation
sur une cassette vhs
avec le risque effectif pour ceux qui ne
passe pas bien à la télé d'être recalé
au niveau des études etc
puis nous après pour en fait des caisses
à partir de là il faut affronter jusqu'à
et faut y aller plein d'ardeur et puis
pas parce qu'il s'est cassé
ici des psychologues des cadres vienne
leur apprendre à remplir un cv à se voir
tel que l'on est devant un futur patron
en un mot répondre à l'angoissé de ces
jeunes comment franchir avec succès la
phase préliminaire à la gauche
c'est vrai qu'il faut peut-être qu'ils
se positionnent comme des gens qui ont
tout à apprendre
avec à la fois j'allais dire le côté un
peu élitiste qu'ils ont d'avoir des
têtes bien bien pleine et en même temps
ce qu'on leur demande dans les
entreprises parce qu'on est on est on
est toujours dur dans les entreprises
une certaine forme d'humilité
bref si l'idée de vous retrouver devant
le recruteur d'une grande entreprise
vous effraie avant de vous présenter
fait donc de la télé c'est un bon
entraînement angleterre france demain
après midi à twickenham tout lé transit
du rugby le savent
parmi eux bien sûr de purs amateurs du
noble sport mais aussi des hommes
d'affaires reste us yeux qui ont compris
que le ballon ovale pouvait donner aux
anglais le goût d'autres saveurs jean
danet même si aujourd'hui le fantôme
d'angleterre-france plane sur un
twickhenham vide que les grandes
affaires pas toujours sportive ne
commenceront que demain certains
français bien sûr on tenta mais loin de
ce stade un autre match l'enjeu
s'introduire sur le marché anglais avec
leurs produits et le plus fameux d'entre
eux le vin une cinquantaine de
coopératives françaises du sud et du sud
ouest ont ainsi eu l'idée de venir
soumettre sur leur terrain leurs
nouveaux produits à des anglais au nez
particulièrement experts la majorité
apprécié mais préfère conserver une
certaine réserve
afin d'en savoir encore plus sur chacun
de ces nectars
d'autres font le métier
consciencieusement et se lance sans
retenue dans l'opération pour leur plus
grande satisfaction
le produit est adopté
au niveau pour les clients qu'on a déjà
pour les nouveaux prospects et surtout
pour la promotion des barons total et ce
qui vaut toutes les vingt neuf ans
satisfaction également des 50 opérateurs
pour qui l'opération est plus qu'un
succès en quatre heures d'exposition un
million de bouteilles sont vendues
précommander mieux qu'un salon français
d'importateurs angleterre france a donc
bien commencé et contre l'appui c'est le
vin qui semble l'emporter
c'est peut-être pour cela que la
fédération de rugby président en tête
est venu s'en imprégner
sans doute pour conjurer le mauvais sort
football du mauvais sort pour michel
platini avant la rencontre echos' france
de mercredi prochain
william prunier et forcé pour cause
d'entorse à la cheville le sélectionneur
a décidé de faire appel à deux nouveaux
joueurs le nantais thierry bonalair et
le médecin albert cartier
l'événement aura lieu en direct demain
soir sur antenne 2 c'est la cérémonie
des césar le palmarès des professionnels
du cinéma et aussi l'abondance du choix
puisque laine et 88 a été fertile pour
le cinéma français
nick a le coeur revenus l'emploi nous
donne ses faveurs
catherine deneuve dans drôle d'endroit
pour une rencontre déconcertante dans le
rouge 9 d'une femme abandonnée pour me
pathétique a déjà eu un césar pour le
dernier métro miu miu dans la lectrice
au tour remarquable de cette actrice en
liseuse érotique ironique ludique a
refusé le césar pour la dérobade
il avait la janis dans camille claudel
inédite rebelles n'a jamais été aussi
belle elle n'a jamais été plus folles a
déjà reçu deux césars pour possession et
l'été meurtrière
richard anconina pour itinéraire d'un
enfant gâté explosion d'un acteur en
face de belmondo il est vulnérable et
anonymes devient puissant et
machiavélique avec conviction et charme
a déjà reçu deux césars pour tchao
pantin gérard depardieu magistral
auguste rodin avait reçu un césar pour
le dernier métro jean paul belmondo dans
itinéraire d'un enfant gâté
à l'apogée de sa carrière grâce à claude
lelouch il donne sa carrure sans charme
ses blessures à ce rôle sur mesure
oh
michel deville pour la lectrice belle
revanche pour ce réalisateur raffiné et
rigoureux refusé à cannes luc besson
pour le grand bleu triomphe public pour
cette idole de la jeune génération à la
recherche d'un ailleurs plus bleu est
plus profond
jean jacques annaud pour l'ours champion
du box office pour cette vaste fresque
animalière aux bons sentiments il a
gagné son défi à l'impossible bravo
camille claudel de bruno nuytten le
grand favori succès critique succès
public pour ce coup de génie d'adjani
inspiratrice productrice actrice de cet
hommage à la création et la beauté pure
rendez vous donc demain à 20h30 sur
antenne 2 pour les surprises les mots
sur l'ajoie le dépit peut être pour
certains et bien sûr les stars les
pronostics de pierre de bresse pour le
tiercé et le quartier plus demain à
saint cloud le 1 le 18 le 3 le 16 le 17
le 4 le 5 1 en partant le set vous
rendez vous avec l'information sur
antenne 2 ce soir vous retrouvez
philippe gassot demain bien sûr daniel
bilalian est aussi bernard rapp pour
l'assiette anglaise la semaine prochaine
à 20 heures vous aurez rendez vous avec
hervé claude j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver la semaine d'après très bon
week-end